joining me in the studio now to talk
about consumer behavior and how it's
affecting the German economy is Stefan
quartz he heads the forecasting center
at the keel Institute for the world
economy Stefan thanks for being with us
to begin with tell me I use someone
who's done all of their Christmas
shopping weeks in advance or are you one
of those last-minute buyers no I'm not
I'm done and that's because Christmas is
easy to predict so I don't have any
stress sir with finding gifts today good
good to hear now Germans used to be
known as a nation of savers it seems to
me now that they're plunging more and
more money into the economy they're
spending like crazy is this good news or
should we also be a little bit cautious
well currently the German economy is
operating at normal capacity utilization
levels which is good but it's also true
currently private consumption spending
is driving the economy and we must be
cautious not to over stretch our
capacities and the reason why we are
currently almost booming is not because
people safe less that because incomes
are much higher this year than they were
last year how much does consumer
behavior actually affect the the current
state of the German economy it's one of
their major driving factors investment
spending is also important will become
even more important next year also due
to the low interest rates that this
economy is exposed to but currently
clearly consumption spending is the
number one driver of this economy every
year Stefan we always like to see how
the German economy performed and how
institutes actually predicted the
performance of the German economy I have
to say that your Institute did do pretty
well Stefan here's the ranking of 50
economic institutions and their
forecasts for German economic growth in
2050 in first place is the aliens
insurance giant followed by your
Institute for the world economy in Kiel
and in third place is Dusseldorf
crow economic policy institute the IM k
now you predicted one-point-seven
percent growth for 2050 which looks like
it's going to be spot-on far better than
for example the OECD Deutsche Bank and
even Germany's central bank so Stefan
can you tell me why was your Institute's
prediction well quite better than the
rest well we should not overestimate
these rankings because you can be right
for the wrong reasons and you can be
wrong for the right reasons our business
cycles forecast is much more than just
having a couple of numbers that then
later on evaluate it therefore okay the
performance was good we are satisfied
and I'm very satisfied with the
performance of my team but whether a
forecast is good or not cannot be judged
only by looking whether it came true or
not this current very low oil price that
we're seeing is this something that's a
blessing or a curse well it shifts
purchasing power from the oil producers
to the importers of oil and this is one
of the reasons why we see consumer
spending so strong at the moment in this
country but at the same time pronounced
ups and downs of the oil price are
disrupting production structures in the
world economy and is therefore causing
some trouble yeah exactly we do know
that the price of oil is likely to
influence monetary policy for example
one of the reasons that inflation has
yet to pick up in the eurozone and
possibly also why central banks continue
to pump relatively cheap money into the
economy but is that the right strategy
no it is not central banks should just
ignore this temporary effect of the oil
prices and just look at the domestic
factors that also contribute to
inflation and the over-expansion airy
monetary stance almost all over the
Western world is really a critical risk
factor for the world economy let's look
ahead to next year very briefly can we
expect to see the price of oil continue
to fall we don't see it
falling further but we do not see a
quick recovery of the oil price as well
so probably the world economy will be
provided with cheap oil over there short
and medium-term well Stefan quotes thank
you very much for joining us and of
course have a wonderful holiday season
thank you